today social democrat olaf schultz took
the reins of power from angela merkel
took the oath of office and took his
place in a new political chapter in
europe's largest democracy the transfer
of power was modest but meaningful there
was little ceremonial pomp and
circumstance on offer today instead a
generous showing of loyalty to the
country's basic law
this is the moment that angela merkel
officially handed over power to her
successor
leaving the political stage after 16
years in power and 31 years in politics
the official ceremony inside the
chancellery here in berlin included
speeches from the former and current
chancellors let's have a listen
congratulations to your chancellor dear
olaf
i know from my own experience that it is
a moving occasion to be elected to this
office
as you perhaps can imagine it is an
exciting fulfilling job and a demanding
one but if you approach it with
enthusiasm then it's perhaps one of the
most beautiful jobs there is to bear
responsibility for this country
i sincerely wish you good luck and every
success for our country
i think it's something very special to
be federal chancellor of this republic
it's a great challenge
i'm very grateful that the citizens of
this country and the german bundestag
have given me the mandate to do this
the fact that you and i were able to
share so many experiences together will
help me fulfill my role
thank you again for the work you've done
and to discuss this historic day here in
germany i'm joined tonight by jessica
berlin jessica is a german american
political analyst and commentator she's
a familiar face to our viewers jessica
it's good to have you back on
the program
before we we talk about the the new
chancellor and the new former chancellor
i'd like to focus on what we saw today
angela merkel transferring power to olaf
schultz after 16 years at the top of
government
talk to me about the significance of
what we witnessed today
this is truly a historic day for all of
us here in germany it's the end of an
era and for an entire generation of
germans they're facing something
completely new anyone who was born in
the last 20 years in germany and across
the world has only known angela merkel
as the german chancellor
so for them it will be a new experience
but also for all germans we're starting
a new era with the first ever
three-party coalition in germany's
history so this is truly a historic day
it was hard not to have goosebumps
watching the peaceful transition
honestly yeah that is true i mean we
know that germany has huge challenges
but its politics are not as polarized as
those that we see in the united states
and after what we saw following last
year's presidential election culminating
in the january 6th riot at the capitol
and when you add to that members of the
u.s congress openly embracing subtle and
not so subtle calls for violence against
other members of congress
when you consider all of that
is there a message that can be sent
from berlin to washington tonight
absolutely
what we saw today was a clear reminder
and message not only to washington but
to the world
that the peaceful democratic transfer of
power is something sacred
it's something that calls for humility
and respect
and in no country um more so than
germany do we understand this our
ancestors and even uh our living
ancestors have fought and died for
germans to have the right for this
peaceful transfer of power as well as
the ancestors of all americans and today
millions of people around the world
continue to fight and indeed to die for
their right to peaceful democratic
governance so this message from germany
to washington i hope is received loud
and clear there is another way and we
have to protect and respect the
sacredness of our peaceful democratic
transitions yeah it shows just how
precious this peaceful transfer of power
really is let's focus now on the new
chancellor olaf schultz the new leader
of germany whom the world will soon get
to know here's more
the 63-year-old former mayor of hamburg
is seen as a pragmatist an effective
operator in times of crisis
as finance minister schultz set aside
his reputation for caution during the
peak of the covet 19 pandemic and
massively increased public borrowing to
prop up the economy it gave his
popularity a significant boost
following the election he secured a
coalition agreement to govern with the
greens and the free democrats
a combination that's never been tried
before but that schultz says has big
potential
we are not about lowest common
denominator politics but about high
impact politics
we want to dare to do something about
climate change the restructuring of our
industry
the modernization of the country the
strengthening of social cohesion
we dare to make more progress
bold goals in the face of immediate
challenges with germany tackling its
worst covet 19 search yet and europe
grappling with a fallout from brexit and
a crisis on the eu's border with belarus
olaf schulz will soon have to prove
whether he can deliver leadership in
times of crisis as chancellor too
jessica the most important question for
our international viewers how different
will german foreign policy be under olaf
schultz compared to what we have known
under angela merkel
well that's really the million dollar
question
olaf jones has made clear that he's
striving for continuity with the last
administration's foreign policy this of
course makes sense coming from schweitz
he himself was vice chancellor in the
past government and also finance
minister so for him staying the course
makes sense however the incoming green
party has taken over the foreign
ministry now under foreign minister
analina berbuk and she has made clear
that she wants to take a harder stance
against human rights abusers and stand
up more for human rights protection and
democratic values in the world so it
remains to be seen who really gets to be
in the driving seat between the
chancellery and the foreign ministry
when these issues arise as they are sure
to do in the coming months and in the
coming year
and i i think we can say tonight for the
for the trans-atlantic community
chancellor
schultz he looks like an early christmas
present doesn't he
an early christmas present well we'll
we'll see if if that is the case for for
the full transatlantic community but one
thing is clear he's certainly an early
christmas present for outgoing
chancellor merkel who will be very happy
that the transition was completed before
the holidays so she can get a
well-deserved rest and enjoy the break
yeah that's true she if anyone deserves
a present it is angela merkel um this
christmas there are two foreign policy
flash points um i'd like to discuss with
you the first being the nordstrom 2
natural gas pipeline that links russia
to germany merkel as we know she
defended this project to the end of her
career
what will chancellor schultz do
especially if it looks like a russian
invasion of ukraine is imminent
it's a very difficult question
honestly olaf schultz thus far has
refused to answer the question clearly
he even this evening earlier on a german
public broadcaster interview
said that there would be consequences if
russia invaded ukraine but hedged on the
answer of what those consequences might
be this is a difficult position for him
because his party of course has been
traditionally quite close to russia and
pushed for closer ties conciliatory ties
with russia over the years however the
eu the green party with which he is now
ruling and the united states are clearly
against north stream too and so if
russia should in fact invade ukraine or
take any other aggressive
measures against allies of nato of
germany
he will be increasingly isolated in his
position that north stream too should go
forward and russia should continue to be
placated yeah and olaf schultz cannot
say that he is the
vladimir putin whisperer the way angela
merkel
could say right
certainly not um and his party is also
known as i mentioned for being close to
putin um um former chancellor gerhard
schroeder also of the spd um is even
sitting in the board of gazprom so these
these issues
make it very difficult for shorts to
continue a a overly overtly uh
pro-russia stance if russia should begin
to push boundaries
second flashpoint
china where will germany stand in a
world that is increasingly taking sides
between what looks like a u.s lead camp
and a chinese-led camp
germany will definitely try to defuse
any sense of a bipolar
world power situation arising it's in
nobody's interest for a return to a cold
war style polarization
really the key question will be will
german foreign policy
start to put its money where its mouth
is on human rights for years of course
the german government has spoken out
openly in support of human rights in
china in particular around hong kong and
xinjiang the repression and internment
of uyghur citizens of china but at the
end of the day those words were not
converted into action and serious
economic political consequences for
china annalina berboch the new foreign
minister will be pushing for that to
happen but it remains to be seen if
those worlds will be backed up with
action
furthermore the main thing that germany
can do is also reach out to other asian
powers rising smaller asian powers in
eastern and southeast asia and
critically in latin america and africa
as well and create a global alliance of
aspiring democracies or emerging
economies where it's in our common
interest to maintain global stability
and this hopefully can be the role
germany plays in keeping a geopolitical
balance do you see a a german diplomatic
boycott of the olympics
in china
that would be for german standards a
very
radical step i would be surprised to see
it at this point i think
there would have to be a change in the
status quo from the chinese side before
germany would take that step
but let's see what happens in the coming
weeks if the us will be pressuring other
states other countries to take that step
but germany i think does not want to
come out of the box antagonizing
unnecessarily countries like china and
russia
they'll really be put to the test um if
and when russia and china take great
aggressive steps of their own to which
germany needs to respond jessica i have
to ask you before we run out of time
we've got video we want to show you you
tweeted about the new chancellor today
being given a basket of apples
um inside the parliament i mean it it is
strange
maybe we could show that video what do
you think that signifies i mean it it's
just unusual isn't it a basket of apples
inside parliament i know i i laughed out
loud when i saw that and apparently the
mp who gave uh chancellor schwartz the
basket of apples is an independent who
doesn't belong to to any of the
coalition parties um or the traditional
parties and therefore did not give the
traditional gift of a bouquet of flowers
but came with a basket of apples so i
hope there's an inside joke there or
maybe who knows you can find that mp and
and bring him or her onto the show to
explain it it's like it's like you
tweeted an apple a day maybe keeps the
opposition
away
we will see
jessica berlin jessica as always good to
have you on excellent analysis tonight
thank you
thank you brent
germany has a new chancellor today the
social democrat olaf schultz
took the oath of office and took the
reigns of power from angela miracle it
was a moment in which political history
was written right here in berlin merkel
the most powerful woman in the world
handed over all of her authority in the
first transfer of power that the country
have seen in 16 years her successor
tonight promising germany a new
beginning
german chancellor
this was the moment he's long waited for
a standing ovation in the bundestag
where schultz won a majority of votes
from lawmakers
[Applause]
and when asked if he accepted their
decision for him to lead a country of
over 80 million people
affirm yes
[Applause]
[Music]
then flowers and fist bumps for an
occasion that doesn't happen very often
schultz is just the ninth post-war
chancellor of germany
and its first in 16 years
the final key moment the oath of office
i swear that i will dedicate my efforts
to the well-being of the german people
promote their welfare protect them from
harm uphold and defend the basic law and
the laws of the federation perform my
duties conscientiously and do justice to
all
that means an end to the long era of
this chancellor
lawmakers gave angela merkel a standing
ovation as the session started no longer
a member of parliament merkel had to
look on from the spectators gallery
just a few hours later merkel with the
same stoicism that marked her time in
office handed over the chancellory to
olaf schultz
[Applause]
congratulations to your chancellor dear
olaf
i know from my own experience that it is
a moving occasion to be elected to this
office
as you perhaps can imagine
it is an exciting fulfilling job and a
demanding one but if you approach it
with enthusiasm then it's perhaps one of
the most beautiful jobs there is
to bear responsibility for this country
i sincerely wish you good luck and every
success for our country
and while merkel leaves the chancellory
for the very last time olaf schulz gets
to work holding his very first cabinet
meeting as chancellor
his government a three-party center-left
coalition wants to make germany greener
fairer and more modern
but before all that it will face its
first true test
how to deal with the severe fourth wave
of the coronavirus pandemic
and on this historic
day of politics here in germany i'm
joined by our political correspondent
leonard hammerstein she's been following
the events today it's good to see you
leone let's talk about what we saw today
there was no real pomp in circumstance
it was i dare say a graceful transfer of
power but because it was
so easily done isn't this a day that
calls for celebration
well yes brent you're right in many ways
this was a quite german transition of
power
you know there were lots of procedural
steps to follow it's quite unglamorous
lots of paper certificates exchanged
hands i mean we do have to remember that
pandemic restrictions make huge
celebrations a little bit more difficult
these days
but
in a way there was a really celebratory
mood in the air when olof schulz was
officially elected as the next german
chancellor by parliament and then
officially sworn in later he also
appointed his new cabinet
so it really was a day when it you know
dawned on the very last person that this
era of anger america is coming to a
close yeah that's right i mean it is a
new chapter that germany is writing now
what can people around the world expect
in terms of foreign policy
chancellor schultz says he wants to work
towards a new start
yes exactly in many ways we can expect
a certain sense of continuity at least
in leadership style you know olaf
schultz is a very experienced negotiator
just like
angela merkel was
he is
seen to be an effective pragmatic leader
in times of crisis and in terms of
foreign policy he is expected um to set
similar you know a similar emphasis on
the role of a strong european union
germany acting within that european
union and also on strong ties with the
u.s a strong transatlantic relationship
but um on the other hand it will be
interesting to see um in the next couple
of you know days and weeks um how olaf
schultz will really behave towards china
and russia and just one very current
example you know the us the uk and
australia have now come out and
announced that they will not center
diplomatic delegations to the winter
olympic games in beijing and olaf
schultz has left open so far whether he
would join this diplomatic you know what
is really a diplomatic boycott over
china's human rights record so we will
see you know will be interesting to
watch him take these very first steps as
german chancellor and we know that
domestically the most pressing problem
most pressing issue of course is the
pandemic and its impact what does
chancellor schultz
what does he inherit from angela merkel
yeah he inherits
a pretty bad situation you know germany
has been hit by the fourth wave of this
pandemic really hard with a couple of
hundred people dying every day um and
hospitals in some parts of the country
being overwhelmed by the amount of
patients um that that are coming in and
they have to send patients to other
parts other areas of the country because
their icus have reached capacity and so
olaf schultz and this new government
really have to hit the ground running
first you know on the top of the agenda
is to convince more people in germany to
get vaccinated as germany has quite a
low rate with uh 69.2 percent of adults
here having gotten two jobs so he really
needs to hit the ground running and and
prove that he can tackle the pandemic
that is very true leonie for hammerstein
reporting on what is an historic day
here at germany leone thank you
you